so in the last video I introduced
transformations and how you can think
about functions as moving points in one
space two points in another and here I
want to show an example of what that
looks like
when the input space is two-dimensional
so this over here is the input space is
just a copy of the XY plane and the
output space is also two-dimensional so
the output space in this case also the
two-dimensional plane and what I'm going
to do I'm just going to first play an
example of one of these transformations
and then go through the details of the
underlying function and how you can
understand the transformation as a
result so here's here's what it looks
like here's what we're going to be going
towards very complicated a lot of points
moving lots of different things
happening here and what's common with
this sort of thing when you're thinking
about moving from two dimensions to two
dimensions given that it's really the
same space the XY plane you often just
think about the input and output space
all at once and instead just watch a
copy of that plane move on to itself and
by the way when I say watch I don't mean
that you'll always have an animation
like this just sort of sitting in front
of you when I think about
transformations it's usually a very
vague thought in the back of my mind
somewhere but it helps to understand
what's really going on with the function
I'll talk about that more at the end but
first let's just go into what this
function is so the one that I told the
computer to animate here is f of X Y as
the input is equal to x squared plus y
squared is the X component of the output
and x squared minus y squared as the Y
component of the output so just to help
start understanding this let's take a
relatively simple point like the origin
so here the origin which is 0 0 and
let's think about what happens to that F
of 0 0 well x and y are both 0 so that
top is 0 and same with the bottom that
bottom also equals 0 which means it's
taking the point 0 0 to itself and if
you watch the transformation what this
means is that the point 0 stays fixed
it's like you can hold your thumb down
on it and nothing really happens to it
and in fact we call this a fixed point
of the function as a whole and that that
kind of terminology
doesn't really make sense unless you're
thinking of the function of the
transformation so let's let's look at
another example here let's take a point
like 1 1 F of 1 1 so in the input space
let's just kind of start this thing over
so we're only looking at the input in
the input space 1 1 is sitting right
here and we're wondering where that's
going to move so when we plug it in x
squared plus y squared it's going to be
1 squared plus 1 squared and then the
bottom x squared minus y squared 1
squared minus y squared well minus 1
squared and plugging things in here so
that's to 0 to 0 which means we expect
this point to move over 2 to 0 in some
way so if we watch the transformation we
expect to watch that point move over to
here and again it can be hard to follow
because there's a lot of moving parts
but if you're careful as you watch it
the point will actually land right there
and you can in principle do this for any
given point and understand how it moves
from one to another but you might ask
hey grant what is the point of all of
this right we have other ways of
visualizing functions that are more
precise and kind of less confusing to be
honest like vector fields are a great
way for functions like this graphs were
a great way for functions with one input
and one output what why think in terms
of transformations and the main reason
is conceptual it's not like you'll have
an animation sitting in front of you and
it's not like you're going to by hand
evaluate a bunch of points and think of
how they move but there's a lot of
different concepts in math and with
functions where when you understand it
in terms of a transformation it gives
you a more nuanced understanding things
like derivatives or the variations of
the derivative that you're going to
learn with multivariable calculus
there's different ways of understanding
it in terms of like stretching or
squishing space and things like this
that doesn't really have a good analog
in terms of graphs or vector fields so
it adds a new color to your
understanding also transformations are a
super important part of linear algebra
there will come a point when you start
learning the connection between linear
algebra and multivariable calculus and
if you have a strong
option of transformations both in the
context of linear algebra and in the
context of multivariable calculus you'll
be in a much better position to
understand the connection between those
two fields